what did you make of what President
Putin had to say yesterday
she's desperate and we all of us were
winning
this is a good side to it the best side
that he's actually instead of thinking
how to get out of this world how to
preserve lives of easy Ukrainian
Russians he's bringing it all up and
trying you know to intimidate all of us
I believe it won't work desperate men do
desperate
desperate sure
we just
believe in the hope that there are some
forces around him who will be able to
tell him that you know we are going to
nowhere we're going down and we're
bringing the whole nation with us
How concerned are you about
um him talking about nuclear weapons and
the fact that he wasn't bluffing I mean
you're next door
when somebody's saying that I'm not
bluffing it's the first sign that
actually bluffing otherwise so they
would do something like prepare the
nuclear nuclear Arsenal they're not
doing that which means that he is still
he's trying to find what is the magic
wunderwaffeine magic wand which will
allow him to get out of this situation
because he's deeply deeply in in
troubles and look at what's happening on
the streets of Moscow Saint Peterborough
in many cities more than a thousand
people already been taken by police
in this protest all the tickets are
bought out and you know people are
trying to avoid this war for for
understandable reasons because we will
fight to the deaths we will lose so many
people but we'll try to get as many of
them as we can
you talked also about partial
mobilization of previous military
personnelis was that a surprise for you
no we expected actually him to go for
the whole mobilization that would be
disaster for both of our nation because
we will be talking about millions of
people brought to the to the
battlefields but who knows what the
partial mobilization in his case his
Minister was talking about 300 000
people how can we control it he can
bring whatever he wants and actually he
was doing it hiding this mobilization
from from the cameras he was doing it
all the way in you know we were trying
to have inmates from the jails everybody
everybody they can throw into this meat
grinder
um
this partial mobilization potential
bigger than that as you were saying does
that push the end of the war further
away
you might say so we we actually believe
that the people is not a big issue the
equipment now this modern war is not
like you know the one wall of the men
and fighting with the access against
another one that's the problem is that
he these people are not trained the
people are not equipped and they are not
there yet they have to be mobilized they
will come
to the battlefield since three weeks
maybe in the months unprepared
unmotivated you know the people saying
that you can actually buy willingness of
somebody to kill somebody but not
actually today for the money so this is
the difference between our very
motivated forces which are now on a wave
of success and the forces which he will
be throwing in in this grinder wave of
The Rave
how is Ukraine going to react to this
latest threat
was the world registered in the
president zilinski said that we will do
what we it's not changing our plans that
first we will do what we have to do to
preserve our population against possible
hoping the problem but possible the
Nuclear Strike we are preparing for that
we have already you know the gas masks
been estimated around the Ukraine so
preparing our infrastructure in case he
would go for something stupid like that
but we will it's not changing our plans
we will just adapt them to the situation
so you're preparing we're preparing for
everything yes gas masks enough for that
no it's not enough for the whole the
medicine special medicines the
infrastructure how how we disperse
people so we are doing that very
unfortunate we are one of those a couple
of Nations who actually know what is
that nuclear threat what is so after
Chernobyl we've been suffering since
then all the 30 plus years so we know
what is that
do you think he would be desperate
enough to do that or do you think that
he's saber rattling I believe that he's
so bull rattling but at the same time uh
he might take into consideration that
his Arsenal might not work all of it I
mean he expected then that this is
Wonder Waffen he will come with it
everybody will run from the battlefield
but no we managed to to kill so many
Rockets coming at us so he has to take
it into considerations half of them are
falling down from the skies because they
are not supported that maintained not
good enough so I believe the people
around him especially military military
experts will tell him that this is risky
it doesn't mean that we will win
um yesterday at the U.N general assembly
in New York
um president selinski who you've
mentioned talked about the just
punishment for Russia what does that
look like
first two sanctions this is civilized
way of punishing the aggressor and
that's what's something the world the
whole world already settled in so we
believe that we still have to go and
isolate Russia to the point when
internal forces will will change the
situation we're not going to change the
Russian system for themselves they have
to take care of what they are not happy
with in their own Nation but isolate
this this is you know this is disease we
have to isolate this tyranny from rest
of the world we bound to be that big
geographically you don't so if we manage
to keep them away from the Civilized you
know ways of they will soon relate to
the healthy forces within the society
will grow and change the system itself
how much sympathy do you have for the
people of Russia who didn't want this
one
problem with these people that they
allowed their system to grow in some in
something horrible you know they didn't
change their leader for many many years
and obviously in many many cases human
cases when people are having no limits
to their power or they believe they have
no limits they're becoming somebody like
putting we also had the president at
some point in the early years who wanted
to go for the third term although we
have only two but people said no and our
system got it each and every next
president who's coming regardless of how
good they were they knew that there are
some rules and they have they can try
ban them people won't be happy but will
never break them with Russians it didn't
happen the same was Belarus it happened
guys the same guy with the system
somebody some of the generations live
through the exactly the whole life with
this guy they are not happy with that so
these leaders have to take this into
into account
how much
um thanks should there be to the the de
facto leader of Saudi Arabia
um for the release of prison Civil War
at this moment we're thinking everybody
helping you know we have so many of them
out and we're quite happy that we
managed to get your boys back home so
the president Doan the Saudi Arabia we
were thankful to everybody who helped us
to achieve this if they can do
everything that's the only thing they
can do at least they've done this we are
thankful
and do you take into account
um their human rights
history
absolutely and never been easy you know
to talk to have this moral sacrifices
but at the same time we hope that
nothing was in negotiations which would
which would you know somehow allow us to
think that we sacrificed somewhere we
as far as I know the deal is that we're
exchanging people we're not going
anywhere further what they're trying to
do themselves trying to raise their
public profile and that's that's
probably what they're trying to achieve
but that's let's let's leave it for this
particular case with them okay that's
something for the future and what about
Liz truss that we know that um the
Ukrainian people very fond of Boris
Johnson what about his successor
I believe that Ukrainian people yeah
they really liked Boris Johnson they
still love him but at the same time they
do understand that Boris Johnson is the
just top of the of the whole mountain of
support and he was on TV because they
know that he is he's a leader and he was
you know pushing the system in the right
direction so there is the role of new
prime minister you which U.S Nations
selected to promote this calculation to
push
we hope that she will be able to make
another step so push even further at
least what she was saying in the U.N
yesterday what I was having with the
concessions with her exchanges when she
was a foreign secretary saying that this
is a right person for us this is for you
to decide who is Ryan right person as a
prime minister for you
uh she certainly promised another 2.3
billion pounds matching at the monies
that have been provided this year that
must be very welcome it is very welcome
and I have to tell you that this is the
right investment look at it you're not
wasting your money you actually all of
us were achieving something who would
expect that we will be able uh withstand
not just withstand pressure more than
200 days in the so-called two days or
three days invasion of Russians we're
actually achieving military victories on
the front this is so-called second
biggest army whatever they call them and
we manage all together we managed to to
defeat them and what would you like to
say to reassure the British public who
are struggling with their energy bills
this winter and they feel that that is
as a direct result of the war in Ukraine
and they'll be struggling to keep their
children warm
you're right there are a couple of
things which we all of us have to be
aware and we we're not just trying to
keep our children when we were trying to
keep them alive this is the first this
is moral obligation of all of us to help
I remember when I was in school I was
bringing my breakfast money to help your
kids of your miners who at that time we
were told suffering on the level so kids
in the schools had to help them and send
their money so that there are you know
there is always you have to have
somebody it was the with Energy prices
rising this is also the Russians are
fighting with the bombs with us but with
the gas prices with you and the third
thing I wanted to bring that's we
actually probably are too late to this
change
which we all was expected the green
trends of transformation whatever we
call it we have to get off this hook of
energy of gas from Russia and especially
from The Tyranny Israel like Russia we
welcome the normal Market relationships
but obviously Russia is not the the
reliable partner in Market War over by
Christmas
yeah I'd love to them that's probably
2023.
yeah you don't think it's going to be
over by Chris
if anything changes dramatically not
even on the grounds because we are
pushing but we we respect the enemy we
understand that they're strong that they
have huge army they have huge stockpiles
of ammunition and everything
something changes in Russia the war will
be ended in the day
but if it doesn't and now we will push
them until we reach the our boundaries
and again nobody's threatening Russia
they they have no moral or any other
right to use or even threatened with
nuclears nobody's threatening them
um it was good to see your first lady
here paying her respects to her majesty
Queen Elizabeth
um have you spoken to your president of
late how's he doing
she's doing fine especially when he he
see that you know it's working
and the support is here and more and
more leaders are actually joining the
club of un and us and trying sort of
stiffening up their splines and the
coming with more assistance and then
good words and political and economic
support so we are happy that this
happening and you know we're opening up
again we open up for business our
delegations start to go outside like
this the first lady in the Prime
Minister was with her so we were talking
again about trade deals like with you
the digital new digital trade agreement
so things things are start rolling again